c'est c'est une période de ma vie
ce que je dis c'est non c'est ça a été
beaucoup de changements et
dans le public il va falloir mettre des
verbes
revenez on dirait votre mère là revenez
non mais voyons franchement
j'avais pas pensé à cette question
moi cette vidéo qu'est-ce que je me dis
la question c'est la question
bordel
j'ai l'impression que les bandes sont
énervées
est-ce que aujourd'hui tu regrettes et
qu'est-ce que tu fais aujourd'hui est-ce
que ça s'est passé est-ce que tu veux
mieux est-ce que tu le referais voilà ce
que vous avez encore des menaces voilà
c'est ça alors déjà
ok donc pas tout de suite
non mais qu'est-ce que tu deviens déjà
ce que je deviens tu fais plus de vidéos
comme ça ça y est non j'en ai pas fait
depuis quelques temps
tu fais quoi maintenant je viens de
finir de décrire un livre pourquoi sur
ton histoire ouais ce que j'ai vécu
ouais je dis quoi dans ton livre
je parle des personnes qui sont
harcelées je parle des personnes qui
sont sur les réseaux exposés rapidement
je parle de ce que c'est que d'être
harcelé sur les réseaux et de façon
incontrôlée comme ça mais toi tu as
pas le sentiment aussi d'avoir harcelé
des gens en faisant ça qui sont tombés
sur la vidéo
je pense qu'il y a des gens j'ai vu j'ai
entendu et
[Musique]
moi dans la question est-ce que je
regrette est-ce que j'ai fait j'ai
conscience que j'ai pu peut-être faire
souffrir des gens alors moi je me
demande aussi les gens est-ce qu'ils ont
conscience qu'ils ont pu faire souffrir
et ce qu'ils ont conscience de souffrir
parce que tu as la bonne place quand on
remette à la bonne place qui sait qui a
vraiment réellement frappé des gens qui
c'est qui a réellement harcelé qui c'est
qui a réellement été en bac c'est
carrément été tout en groupe pour
attaquer une seule personne qui sait qui
a je trouve mais en même temps à cause
de
mais vous êtes bizarre ce soir Benjamin
non mais c'est vrai parce que moi je
vous ai toujours soutenu mais là je
trouve que vous partez un peu dans tous
les sens la question elle est claire
est-ce que vous regrettez toutes ces
vidéos qui ont choqué plein de gens
est-ce que vous avez des regrets si
c'était à refaire est-ce que vous leur
feriez
je pense qu'on a beaucoup de leçons à en
tirer
par exemple la première de ma vidéo des
réactions des gens de des comportements
des gens mais
j'ai jamais voulu faire du mal du coup à
des gens qui ont pu être ou réponse
est-ce que tu la referais c'était ça la
question si c'était à refaire un an
avant je pense que oui voilà merci je
pense que oui malgré tout ce qui vous
est arrivé je pense que oui pourquoi
parce que ça a révélé des comportements
chez les gens que je pense bon il faut
se rappeler non il faut se souvenir et
c'est pour ça que tu as souhaité aussi
revenir t'exprimer ce soir parce que
toi toi est-ce que tu seras plus jamais
la même personne que ce que tu as été
avant
vous jouez un rôle en fait on n'arrive
pas à vous cerner où est-ce que vous
êtes sous substance il
[Applaudissements]
non
vous êtes vous êtes comme ça dans la vie
tout le temps
dans la vie parce que les spectateurs
veulent
venir
des groupes pour les personnes qui sont
harcelées comment ça se passe
à l'université ça se passe bien ça se
passe bien
est-ce que ça se passe mieux pour toi
est-ce que ta vie il se passe mieux
parce qu'à un moment tu avais vu revenir
ici tu étais
ça dépend ça dépend ça dépend mais ça va
tu es carrément étonné parce que tu dis
avec moi maintenant ce soir en direct
est-ce que tu penses c'est sincère que
tu as fait du coup avancer quelque chose
dans la société
[Rires]
qui l'aurait refait est-ce que tu penses
que du coup ça a fait avancer quelque
chose dans la société tu as pris un
risque mais il y a quelque chose qui du
coup les gens pris conscience de quelque
chose non je suis pas sûr je suis pas
sûr que ça ait fonctionner je sais pas
est-ce que tu as des regrets
la question il y a une demi-heure
est-ce que tu dis ce soir
aucun enseignement de ce qui s'est passé
vous excusez pas vous continuez à poster
des vidéos dégueulasses bah si on lui a
demandé continue à poster des vidéos
dégueulasses sur les réseaux sociaux ou
vous l'avez des vitres avec un Coran
vous passez votre temps à faire la
victime en disant ah je vais me retirer
des réseaux puis non puis oui puis non
puis oui puis non en fait
encore tous les jours
la vérité c'est que je pense que vous
êtes de la peine quoi j'ai pas dit Théo
depuis trois mois bah là tu en as fait
une récemment j'en ai vu une social et
voir ton je suis allé regarder ton truc
le nouvel an j'ai souhaité les bonnes
années c'est pas ça je pense que tu peux
faire de la peine à tous et moi on n'en
peux plus
quand tu la Grèce Guillaume
à 19h56 on était avec Benjamin Leduc
vous savez ce jeune homme qui avait
énormément fait parler de lui notamment
par sa vidéo it warquée dans une église
Benjamin aujourd'hui c'est quoi ta vie
tu as envie de quoi
là j'ai envie
d'en manger là
[Rires]
dans mon nouvel appart
j'ai envie par cette envie de vivre une
vie comment est-ce que tu as envie de
continuer sur les réseaux à faire chier
le monde où est-ce que tu as envie non
j'ai pas envie de dire
c'est ça
dans la rue sur les réseaux que ta vie
est dur est-ce que ta vie est dure pour
toi
non mais un peu un peu oui des fois un
peu ouais des fois mais c'est pas
souvent tous les jours
tout le monde lui saute dessus tout le
monde tout le monde se moque de lui tout
le monde rit de lui moi j'ai de la peine
pour vous jeune homme parce que je vous
retrouve comme pratiquement il y a un an
et en fait je vous retrouve encore tout
aussi perdu qu'il y a un an donc moi je
sais pas je vous vous êtes en tous santé
voilà je sais pas ce qu'on essaye de
vous faire dire ici et voilà moi
j'aimerais savoir si vous êtes mieux si
vous allez mieux si vous vous sentez
mieux si des gens vous entendez la main
parce que là on a on a entendu parler
aussi de gens qui ont souhaité votre
mort carrément donc voilà voilà
c'est un peu trop hein
comment vous sentez-vous comment est-ce
que vous sentez que vous avez le
sentiment que ça va un petit peu mieux
que vous envoyez un petit peu plus clair
dans votre vie et est-ce que vous savez
à peu près où vous avez envie d'aller
maintenant j'ai appris j'ai appris de
décalage
ça pourrait être mon fils c'est pour ça
que je parle comme ça
qui a essayé de le comprendre quand tu
le revois un an après je disais que
c'était un enfant perdu bah apparemment
et il s'est pas retrouvé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis effectivement je suis pas
d'accord avec avec l'agressivité et plus
on rit Jean-Marie plus il est perdu si
vous avez écrit un livre c'est que quand
même vous avez structuré vos pensées moi
ce qu'on m'avait dit c'est que la
condamnation justice que vous avez eu
les 4500 euros d'amende etc et Fred
justice parce que le curé vous avez
attaqué pour avoir pénétrer dans
l'église on m'avait dit que ça vous avez
fait quand même beaucoup réfléchir et
que vous vous étiez dit je ne le referai
pas alors peut-être que mes informations
ne sont pas bonnes mais est-ce que ça a
changé quand même ça c'est qu'on a aussi
en justice vous êtes dit là j'y vais
mollo maintenant et je fais autre chose
qui m'a fait qui m'a fait réfléchir à ce
que j'avais fait enfin
j'ai eu le temps de réfléchir avant et
devoir venir le chemin ça t'a fait de la
peine d'avoir fait de la peine à des
gens vraiment ça c'est important tu le
dises
ta maman
c'est gentil merci ah oui parce qu'on
l'avait vu triste à l'époque comment
elle va elle va bien elle est contente
que ça se calme un peu tout ça pour toi
elle est contente parce qu'elle avait
très peu pour toi ouais elle a toujours
peur
est-ce que vous vous avez peur pour vous
avez peur un peu oui mais oui
[Rires]
tout le monde a droit à une seconde
chance je pense que ce serait bien que
vous puissiez faire des choses bénévoles
pour pour l'église de pouvoir faire des
choses pour pouvoir justement rattraper
ce que vous avez fait non mais vraiment
c'est vrai que tout le monde a droit à
une seconde chance vous pouvez toujours
faire des choses positives je sais pas
une cagnotte un truc pour justement
changer ce truc et faire des choses pour
l'église de votre village par exemple
Mathieu c'est bien
je ne t'en voudrais jamais de t'en
donner de tes sauf que j'ai le sentiment
que je t'ai posé la question tout à
l'heure et je te dis est-ce que tu
pourrais éventuellement le refaire oui
tu as un petit peu riche ça veut dire
qu'éventuellement tu pourrais le refaire
en fait
dans le futur c'est un truc tu dis pas
plus jamais tu pointes tu dis tu pourras
le refaire non c'est pas prévu
il y a eu des rumeurs claire comme quoi
tu avais pensé à un moment à mettre fin
à tes jours est-ce que c'est vrai ouais
ouais pourquoi
pas
n'était plus fun je m'ennuyais enfin non
je vais parce que
voilà ça c'est un buzz voilà là
et que tu arrêtes de faire des vidéos
comme ça et tu reprends une vie normale
et que tu deviens sympathique et comme
tu es comme tu étais certainement avant
tout ça tu vas reprendre une vie normale
c'est moi quand j'entends que tu dis que
tu vas mettre fin à tes jours c'est pas
la solution la solution ce serait mais
on le sait tous quand on quotidien
devient trop compliqué
ça tu vas aller tu vas donner raison à
ceux qui t'ont harcelé en plus donc ça
c'est une connerie
tu t'es fait suivre ou pas depuis
finalement non
j'ai voulu aller en clinique pour me
faire interner ou que j'ai entendu dire
et finalement je l'ai pas été parce que
apparemment j'avais pas de j'ai pas eu
de diagnostic en fait pour me définir
comme tu as envie de teint interné pour
je pensais que je pensais que j'étais
malade en fait je pensais que j'étais
fou je pensais que ça c'est important
qu'il fallait m'interner ou quoi et
finalement personne n'a voulu m'interner
donc
je suis resté chez moi j'ai réfléchi sur
moi-même et maintenant j'ai un psy aussi
qui mais
ouais quand j'ai voulu vraiment être
aidé et être internet simplement je n'ai
pas été et j'ai trouvé mon injustice
aussi là dedans mais c'est vrai que le
jour de l'an tu avais posté une vidéo
plutôt positive il y a plein de gens qui
m'ont dit donc Guillaume qui est une
connerie sa vidéo était très posée
de vidéo depuis combien de temps tu as
pas de possible vidéo polémique depuis
combien de temps
polémique oui depuis combien de temps
au moins trois mois combien au moins 3
mois
mais polémique j'en sais rien chacun
considère vidéo polémique comme il le
veut ça c'était poli
est-ce que Benjamin vous êtes un peu
moins seul que vous n'étiez un moment il
y a quelques temps vous avez dit dans ma
vie je n'avais qu'un qu'une amie
l'alcool est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ça va
mieux est-ce que vous avez un entourage
auprès de vous est-ce que vous retrouvez
un peu de joie de vivre
petit à petit c'est un peu compliqué
mais tu as des potes ou pas Benjamin pas
beaucoup le pote qui avait fait la vidéo
avec toi toujours pas avec toi fini
ce soir je peux plus brancher quoi
ou tu es heureux dans la vie
[Musique]
avant tout ce qui était tombé dessus ou
tu étais tu étais pareil
[Musique]
au départ je vous ai vraiment défendu et
après je vous ai accablé en fait je sais
pas qui vous êtes en fait je sais pas si
vous êtes perdus ou je sais pas si vous
jouez le perdu je sais pas si vous
fabriquez du buzz parce que c'est votre
fond de commerce mais en fait je sais
pas si c'est le buzz qui vous intéresse
ou l'objet du buzz ce que vous mettez
dans le buzz est-ce que c'est le Twer
que dans l'église est-ce que c'est le
Coran pour nettoyer une vitre en fait je
suis complètement perdu face à vous et
je ne sais pas mais en revanche moi je
vous défends et je sais que je suis
totalement minoritaire sur le plateau
parce que je pense que les religions
sont beaucoup trop sacrées et moi je
pense que c'est important en France de
pouvoir se moquer des religions pas des
croyants mais des religions et ça je
pense que c'est très très important et
pour ça moi j'ai envie de vous prendre
avec vous mais j'ai dit que je suis
minoritaire
je pense que c'est important je trouve
que la religion est beaucoup trop
présente dans la sphère publique la
religion c'est le privé c'est l'intime
c'est à la maison c'est dans l'Église
dans les synagogues dans les mosquées
mais je trouve qu'on en parle beaucoup
trop il y a beaucoup trop de
prosélytisme et je trouve que c'est donc
très important de désacraliser
c'est la question boudin non pas du tout
il aurait déjà oui oui j'ai défendu
aussi mais il faut s'excuser oui pour
moi j'ai changé d'avis par rapport à lui
il y a eu la condamnation en justice et
puis il y a eu plein de gens qui m'ont
dit que vous les aviez rendu malheureux
malheureux parce que dans leur justement
dans leur pratique de la religion ils ne
veulent pas ça et moi je je les écoute
aussi
beaucoup de gens
en France ça peut être un brûlot ça peut
être très compliqué ça peut justement
aider des gens et laissez-moi juste
finir ça peut opposer des gens ça peut
créer des conflits ça peut créer des
problèmes entre communautés et je trouve
qu'on a pas besoin de ça en ce moment
donc moi Benjamin honnêtement je vous ai
jamais condamné mais je trouve que vous
devriez vous excuser ça est-ce que vous
avez tendu le bâton pour vous faire
battre avec après vous voilà ce qui
s'est passé après sur les réseaux
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ces gens
les choses intéressantes que ce garçon
dit c'est pendant la pub pardon et
qu'est-ce qui vous a dit pendant la pub
on peut le révéler ou pas bien sûr rien
de mais en fait c'est pas la religion le
sujet c'est un gamin de 18 ans qui est
paumé pardon je n'en veux pas à tes
parents mais qui te laisse un peu paumé
là il me dit ce soir dans un hôtel tout
seul de garde de l'Est je vais rentrer
chez mes parents bien sûr
après ça il va aller dans l'Est il va
aller voir ses parents il est pas très
bien chez ses parents donc il revient à
Paris quand il est à Paris il me dit
j'ai nulle part où aller allez donc je
dors chez un mec de boîte de nuit piano
puis là il dort chez un pilin pierre
tourne chez ses parents il est paumé
tu t'en souviens pas là
et en fait pardon le tout petit message
de leçon à personne j'ai pas d'enfant
peut-être c'est juste à ses parents
c'est ce mot mais il est juste paumé et
la religion la connerie qu'il a fait
dans une église c'est pour exister tu
vois bien qu'il est complètement paumé
il a pas il y a pas de bizarre en
français
toutes les religions raisonnent plus
pour te dire qu'il s'est attaqué aucune
église il s'est attaqué à toute il est
juste paumé complètement quand que quand
tu penses de ce que tu viens de dire
Mathieu Benjamin j'ai pas compris
ou pas du tout pour toi tu es pas paumé
je suis un peu paumé c'est vrai mais je
ne suis pas heureux et quand j'arrive à
Paris je dors chez des gens
c'est grand comme ville [ __ ] à
Strasbourg ce weekend ça c'est grand
comme ville
tu es vraiment
déjà dit
moi je refuse je suis contre tout
blasphème mais tout le monde a une
chance désert une seconde chance donc je
vous ai dit on fait un truc pour les
clés
on peut faire vous pouvez m'appeler si
vous voulez faire du sport arrêtez de
boire de fumer
la sentence [ __ ] merde on est dans la
même génération il m'adore je l'adore
voilà ce que vous avez fait c'est très
mal je refuse le blasphème mais vous
avez le droit à une seconde chance quand
vous trouvez seul appeler SOS infidèle
je serai là c'est gentil
[Musique]
là-bas
l'ombre blanche tu sais que j'étais en
France
allez merci vraiment vraiment je pense
qu'il a fait beaucoup de peine aux gens
avec ce twerk dans l'église il a attaqué
toutes les religions sans exception
alors quand tu dis Géraldine on peut
toucher à la religion tant qu'on touche
pas aux croyants mais quand tu touches à
la religion et une église tu touches
indirectement aux croyant tu fais de la
peine aux croyants moi je suis athée
j'ai pas de religion mais il fait de la
peine quand il fait ça parce qu'il
blesse des gens je suis d'accord et là
on a le droit de la semaine ou oui
d'accord mais tu ouvres une porte si tu
laisses faire lui la prochaine étape
c'est un autre qui va arriver torse nu
un autre qui va arriver en slip etc etc
c'est pour ça qu'à un moment donné il
faut mettre des cadres et dire on ne
joue pas tant que ça blesse les gens on
met bien un cadre il a été conduit il a
été condamné et c'est une bonne chose
est-ce que je vois là ça me fait quand
je t'entends dire faire des études
endroits j'ai envie qu'il fasse des
études en droit j'ai envie qu'il
rééquilibre sa vie j'ai pas envie de le
juger parce que je vois un garçon très
fragile et je vois un garçon qui me fait
peur donc j'ai envie de le laisser
tranquille fais de la mais qui fait peur
pour lui et j'ai envie de le laisser
tranquille et dire fais ta vie et arrête
surtout de t'exposer comme ça on a envie
de t'arrête de texter
comme ça trois fois que tu fais la
première année en droit
ça va l'équilibrer sur quelque chose et
ça va il fait comme tu as dit tout à
l'heure qui se passe un cercle d'amis
qui se trouve des amis parce qu'on voit
quelqu'un de très fragile et ça peut et
moi j'ai peur pour lui franchement il me
fait flipper en fait Kelly en fait moi
le souci c'est que là tu dis que tu es
plus malheureux qu'avant d'accord donc
il sait pas trop c'est un peu plus
malheureux qu'avant est-ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure pourquoi tu recommences
pourquoi tu recommences en fait c'est ta
tête qui me perturbe je suis désolé
regarde bizarrement pourquoi tu
recommences ce genre de choses là tu dis
que tu as arrêté les polémiques depuis
trois mois mais pourquoi il y a trois
mois tu continues encore à faire ces
choses là si ça te rend encore plus
malheureux est-ce que tu as des envies
d'autodestruction en fait est-ce que tu
es mal dans ta peau et tu as besoin
d'aide simplement
la notoriété soudaine que tu as eu à
cause de ça
met un peu tombé dessus du coup mais
ouais sur le coup je pense que ça m'a
plu ça t'a plu je pense que je pense que
ça va bien c'était quelque chose que
j'avais peut-être rêvé d'être quand
j'étais enfant et
mais je t'étais déjà un petit peu avant
ça veut dire et mais ouais ouais c'était
un peu comme à chaque côté
ici sur le plateau comme une sorte de
monstre un peu alimentée par tout ça
déjà ce que je vois pardon il est à côté
de moi la dernière fois que tu étais
venue tu étais gavé d'eczéma tu avais
des plaques tout ça et tous ces snap et
pardon mais c'est non mais c'est vrai ou
pas c'est des signes c'est des signes la
peau s'exprime tout ça tu en as un peu
moins maintenant c'est pas quelqu'un qui
est heureux qui cherche ce notoriété
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est vrai
ça non
Mathieu tu veux pas faire un reportage
là non mais il me touche ce garçon
parce que la religion
aujourd'hui
à des sujets aussi graves il se tirent
une balle dans le pied tout seul si il
aime bien la lumière la notoriété tous
ces trucs là qui le fassent mais
autrement qu'il aille sur Tik Tok faire
des vidéos qui font rire qui est
peut-être la notoriété elle viendra
peut-être fais tes études de droit et la
notoriété c'est pas un truc organisé
genre un
programmeur je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord je te crois sauf qu'après qu'on
te demande si tu regrette tu dis non et
c'est que ce soit pas organisé je veux
bien te croire
comme ça un coup comme ça avec ton pote
que tu te sois fait chauffer je te crois
mais après quand tu fais les carreaux et
tu es dans la Provence avec un livre tu
fais après
quand il fait des carottes le Coran
c'est pas
c'est ça qui fait mal tu comprennes que
tu peux après voilà il y a comme dit
Géraldine il y a la liberté au blasphème
on a le droit non mais après
tu regrettes toutes ces provocations
je regrette dans le sens où ça a pu
faire du mal à quelqu'un voilà si ça a
pu donc
faire souffrir ça a jamais été
l'intention de mes actes mais toujours
la question de
les réactions que ça a provoqué genre tu
vas faire des vidéos
je pense que je vais en refaire
peut-être ouais les vidéos comment
des vidéos normales
donc les vidéos comme ça tu vas arrêter
je peux transmettre des messages sans
faire souffrir des gens et c'est
toujours possible donc c'est ça
Gilles dans les cimetières tout ça tu
n'iras plus tu feras plus non mais c'est
important tu sais c'est important parce
que honnêtement honnêtement il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont dit que là
c'était pas possible tu avais passé un
cap tu avais transgressé je veux bien
que la liberté d'expression mais en fait
ils se sont sentis atteints plus que
dans leur chair dans leur âme dans leur
conviction donc tu as blessé des gens
c'est pour ça que je te dis ça moi je
t'apprécie mais je trouve que c'est bien
parce que avec Cyril là ta formulé des
regrets je trouve que ce serait bien que
tu t'excuses auprès de tous les gens
c'est pas le problème tu n'arrêtes pas
de lui demander de t'excuser auprès des
gens je vais te dire quelque chose
pardon c'est pas c'est pas les gens le
problème aujourd'hui c'est lui aussi
c'est lui c'est lui arrête de s'excuser
il a 18 ans c'est sa plus grande excuse
le problème c'est lui aujourd'hui bien
sûr tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est
lui que tu as dit de s'excuser parce que
il va te dire pour te faire plaisir mais
pas bien c'est un gamin qui va pas bien
qu'elle l'eczéma qui est paumé qui est
c'est ça le le sujet c'est pas qui
s'excuse et qu'il est fait il a 18 ans
comme ça à 19h tant mieux à 19 ans la
chanson lui donne là il s'exprime pas
beaucoup donc je suis désolé il y a
un moment donné il fait pas ses vidéos
là
arrête de dire pas ça c'est justement
parce qu'il est pas armé qu'il est fait
céder aussi exactement tu peux retourner
pour apporter de l'aide aux gens qui
sont harcelés sur les réseaux je vais
faire mon bac et voilà
est-ce que tu peux trouver un petit
boulot par exemple juste tout bête
peut-être d'un petit boulot pour te
payer un petit appartement ou que que tu
aimes un petit studio enfin rien à 15
mètres carrés à Paris ou à Strasbourg
dans la ville de l'Est mais est-ce que
tu veux pas essayer de faire un tout
petit boulot pour essayer de faire
quelque chose ou là tu me dis tout à
l'heure je mange je m'ennuie je m'ennuie
j'aimerais bien faire une expérience
sociale tu vois chercher un petit boulot
demande un petit peu à quelqu'un social
il faut que tu vois les restos du coeurs
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous